hi everybody will come to the
job this is the third series I'm going
to talk
to grass and in this particular time I
am giuseppem a Tully working for the
Center for research computing school of
forest environmental studies and the
library center for scientists social
social science information so today we
are going to to achieve what we can do
it with grass in there an infrared
analysis or geographical data you can
find the slide over here so you can
directly browsing that webpage and you
can start to following up so grass stay
for geographical resource and a little
support system and has been developed
already many years ago today I'm going
to talk about the grid the grass future
has been developed and so on I will
concentrate my attention in the grass
architecture this is quite something
extremely important that are people
struggling so I will spend a lot of time
over here then we will go to the common
structure and the GUI terminal so this
presentation is giving you a general
understanding and then we will use the
common line and the graphical user
interface to try to understand deep what
I'm going to explain over here in the in
the presentation so a bit few few word
about open source of open source concept
free software is a matter of liberty
okay so has been applied from ready many
years this freedom of being able to to
release a software without any
constraints okay constraints in the code
and the code can be really used and
applied to the research and you can
improve it understanding redistribute
and so on is under the new new operating
system okay Foundation Agra new project
has been starting in 84 and now is
running in all the different unix-like
Linux operating system so these allow
you to to to have a big freedom and a
really stable operating system and grass
is one
of the many project inside to the open
source community okay so grass is part
of is part of open source geospatial
foundation that is a foundation that is
including all the open source software
and try to coordinate the activity
between all of them and also especially
in the teaching procedure there is this
Jo for all that is something quite
important that are helping in spreading
the news and spreading the teaching
activity for the different open source
software and of course is very well link
it with other kind of open source
software in geographic space like GTL
post GIS quantum GIS map server open
layers especially this one has been
covering previous workshop but quantum
GIS we will briefly see today and open
server open layer are for the web GIS
interface so the capability of grass to
communicate with all these software
allow you to expanding the analysis even
behind the point where grass cannot do
it so in this context it was a United
States software starting the 84 actually
development since 84 then it was
completely abandoned for like 15 years
and then in end of beginning of 2000 a
group of developer getting back and has
been developed in the last 18 years in a
very powerful way and now there are 350
models that you can do visualization
working with raster vectorization and
again is linked at with the different
software and especially for a
statistical point of view is very useful
because it's linked at with are okay so
these are an advantage that can can push
the calculation not from a geographical
aspect but even from a statistical
aspect so how it works and usually this
scheme is is really just our mother of
in is valid for many software where you
have a bunch of users and some of them
are developers that are working for the
the creation of the open source and they
keep receiving feedback through internet
from the different mailing list people
that define back or documentation
producing sampling data and so on so all
these framework is completely active and
you can receive a lot of information
among all this one don't think that the
open source is a synonym of something
old actually is extremely update on the
current Sciences situation okay because
the developer are really connected with
what with the demand of the user and the
user are asking through mailing list I
need this stuff who can help me who can
develop this and they reply and so it's
very flexible and dynamic in this sense
if you that developers use something is
developing something that nobody is
using because there is no interest after
one or one one or two year he will just
go down you know will not develop even
anymore rather if he's keeping the
community is keeping asking and helping
because then arriving older developers
then is that the open source software is
going up and up so in this context what
grass can do so here you can work mainly
in raster operation for massive data
process and in vector also in vector
operation you for my computation I use
more the raster operation we will see
several application of raster mainly
because all the satellite are raster
image so I always use data from
satellite that are directly under raster
environment and also because the
computer is much efficient in working
with raster because it's just a matrix
okay it's a regular matrix where a
computer can really go fast line by line
and process rather the vector
completely not regular file and the
computer take longer in in process this
kind of information then you can do
different kind of vector analysis and
visualization in to and 3d I mainly use
2d mapping but they're also working in
3d maps in in three maps and volume is
portable in all the different operating
system so you can also install it on the
Mac and under windows with Max is
working a bit better because Mac is
nothing else that fancy fancy Linux on
the back end and with micro windows is
still working but you will not have the
full flexibility and the language
interpreter ability that you have under
Mac and under Linux he has a model
architecture is creeping capability ok
so will we will focus in these scripting
capability for batch processing so these
are advantage for massive data analysis
because you can build up your scripting
procedure and let work Latin the word
run for example in a node and using the
different CPU for from a big computer
cluster so now the architecture so
please hear maximum attention okay so
these opportunities a story now really
really understanding how the software of
architecture is build up so each one of
these box is nothing else that then a
folder ok so imagine that you have a
bunch of this folder in your computer
and this is the architecture that grass
build up in automatically ok so you have
always a grass database that is a
completely empty folder in the beginning
so in our case the grass database is
called OST for Sam and then the name of
the folder for the grass database is
grass database I always use the same
okay then I've under the grass database
you have your location and you have for
example this location is called Europe
under Europe you have the map set that
can be there is always a permanent and
then can be a V model or a piece M and
these are user defined it's something
that you create so again try to remember
always these stairs grass database
location map set and every time that you
have to start a grass location a grass a
session you have to say to the computer
I want to enter in grass database Europe
permanent or cluster Bay Europe v-moda
so you have to give the step where to go
in okay so so this is quite completely
different from other software from from
from ESRI from qgs that you can you can
enter wherever you want you can have
your tea file in the desktop or you can
have the TIFF file in another folder you
can still open it without problem grass
no these structure is very rigid okay
and of course you cannot keep it moving
folder as you want if you take this one
and you bring it outside it's not going
to work okay again because the software
not need always these three steps grass
database Europe and then I'm upset so
keep in mind always and I will keep
working on this concept during the
workshop any question yes please
perfect perfect so when you have a new
completely new project you have to build
up this structure okay so we will see
how to do it so first we will see an
enter and using something that already
exists okay and we will understand the
cut this concept and then we will use it
a new completely completely fire a
completely new file to build up a new
grass database location map set okay but
keep in mind these stairs so is the
difference between difference between
these three folder so the gist database
we say that is just up a completely
empty directory in the beginning that is
all doing the different location I'm
upset okay the location are define it by
coordinate system map projection okay so
you can have a location for each single
map projection that you are using so
these allow you to have different file
under different projection in each one
over the different location so you can
work in for example in United States
United States under nad and in Europe
under la another projection okay so this
is quite rigid and also grass will
complain if you try to take one file
from one project and bring it to the
other one you say no you can't the
location is completely different okay
and then the map set is like your
project you can have different project
that are still working for example under
the same location under the same
projection system but then you can have
for example module for your soil mapping
another model for your vegetation
mapping and so on so this one is given
to you flexibility in building
up your own project and again in the map
set there is always one there is always
one map set that is the fault one that
is the so called permanent so again
these one G's database location map set
this is a default one has been and we
can see why is the default one and then
you can keep adding the different one in
according to your your to user request
so the the architecture is not over over
here is going even deeper okay so here
you can see perfect the same grass
database map a location map set but in a
bigger environment like if you have more
location so for example you can have
more location word Asia and Spain Europe
then inside Europe you have the
different map set ok so if you get
inside one map set then there are all
their different folders ok so the most
important part is up to here to the left
you don't need to remember all this one
on the right but it's good to know why
is this why is built up in this way so
for example inside to the permanent you
can have the vector data or you can have
the raster map so be careful inside to
the raster map you have two different
folder ok so when you're importing a
tiff of our example the TIF doesn't go
in one of them is going everywhere is
going to be splitted in different file
in the different folder so for example
this folder we will have the value of
the pixel really the matrix this one
will have the header the information
about the projection now may recall a
row this one we will have information
about color if he has it this one will
have information it is a floating type
and this one will be information about
the Easter gram
statistic okay so that's why you can you
can't take a TIF and dragging copy/paste
everywhere so you have to use a special
rule of a special condition command to
import the teeth inside to this
structure okay and this is the more
scary one and people that just abandon
this idea of but if you keep in mind
this process these grass database
location and map set you can building up
your procedure without problem ok any
question maybe now is a bit fancy but
for me it's important that you you have
in mind this three-step plus database
location I'm upset and every time you
have to specify the stairs if you are
missing one then is going to complain
the software it's going to say no
location is not that one the map set is
not define it and so on okay for giving
a bit to you an idea is like you start
your are section and you are and you
want to set up the working directory
okay you say ok I work my working
directory is going to be here it's
pretty the same but in this case you
have to have three steps inside to the
working director directory
okay so yes this one is what I described
before for each single roster for a girl
for an inside to the raster cell and
there is always something very important
over here that time I like to comment
from now so one of the default one of
the folder is including the the so
called wind is nothing else that a file
with coordinates of your working region
so be careful about this concept because
it's extremely important and extremely
efficient in in grass and there is no
software there was in our in their old
archive for
then they just don't use it anymore so
the concept of the region of mapset the
region inside to the map set is this one
so consider that I have a tiff that is
big like this big screen but then I want
to work just in this region where is
white okay
I'm not going to cropping anything but
my computation is going to set up only
and coming out only for this region so
of course you can already thinking that
if I process this full TIFF is going to
be long but if I process only this one
is going to be extremely fast because
it's very small so in the mind of the
scripting procedure you can test your
script in this little study area and
then before to run it you just enlarge a
study area to the full computation and
again this is stored in a file that
gives you the coordinates of these very
simple four lines okay with a coordinate
of this point and we will see how to
work with this setting region and what
you can change okay yes perfect parry is
going to your output is going to be only
here it just does not consider but
doesn't mean that your input you are
going to be crop it it is going to be
cropped only the output so your input
they are completely untouched no in case
you want this part you have to rerun the
computation that's why so you tested
everything under a small region and then
when you are assured that you don't have
syntax error that your how to put our
what you want then you say okay let's
leave it run for other two hours with a
full computation okay so and this is
quite appealing because you can keep
work in a fast mode but in retrieve the
result very fast and then when you are
ready for the computation you just leave
it run for the full night and the day
after you have
the full code so grass command they are
really you can identify immediately and
it is quite unique because the grass
command they start all with one letter
and then you have the dot so as soon you
see one letter plus dot and with
following something else means that you
are inside today you are following up
with the code so if for the grass code
so for example the G stay for general
data management so you can think about
for example renaming a raster copy
setting up the G region so everything
that is general rather D is for the
display is not use it anymore because
you there is a graphical user interface
so we are not going to use it they dot
the dot d are the raster with the models
is the one that you are going to use
more and you can do you can think about
our map calc our univariate our
principal component our dot whatever you
want buffering away vector for vector
processing so we buffer we cleaning we
intersect and so on imagery for
satellite image so for example in small
component analysis for satellite image
and this one are for 3d raster process I
didn't use so much but they are coming
really they are doing a lot of work and
developing a lot of models in this
contest this one also the database is
linked at with the vector so they are
going together because you have the
attribute table in a vector are stored
inside to the database and these
database can be linked at with post GIS
ok so if you really need a lot of
working with with the command and this
one psst is for map generation ok when
you have to create a lot of map and so
on but also this one maybe is a bit not
very you use it so much now so let's go
in day let's see how is built up a
comment
so as been born under linux grass so of
course is going to be following the
typical pattern of a bosch language so
abortion language is nothing else that
is nothing else that the language that
is is maintained it in the tech that is
running in the terminal so whenever you
are you you open your Mac or you open
the Linux terminal what you write in the
language terminal is a bash language and
for this concept the syntax oops maybe
already yes so the syntax is always this
one you have a command you have several
flags that are always between square
brackets so whatever is between square
brackets means that is optional rather
parameter in order flags
so in few words you see this one so if
you want to for example you you want to
create a buffer around road network a
typical GIS operation so the command is
going to be our buffer you will have
your input name like your road you are
going to have the output name the
distance every 1 to 3 kilometer and the
unit so as you can see everything that
you put over here is going to be
optional so if you will want to build up
in what line they input parameter input
roads how to put rods buffer distance
every 100 200 and then you give unit
kilometer and the option override to
overfly your your roster so this is as
you can see is is the same syntax over
here for the bash language ok oh the old
is 1 are the parameter over here and
whatever it was
optional it was between square brackets
okay can you see them if you have
already experienced in bit of Bosch or
with our you can translate the syntax in
for our concept let's say okay and all
of them they work in the same way if you
have another command and map calc or
raster neighborhood for filtering and so
on so you just go there and check it how
you which are all there so you can find
all the different GIS operation that you
have in the old software are always are
also in over there in rust in in grass
okay any any question this aspect
okay so we go for the graphical use you
also have a graphical user interface
that you have your name denoted one for
grass and we are going to use this one
but the results on interface with the
QGIS so you can use it Kuja has to open
raster file usually I open this one for
some visualization and and we will see
how to use it also for building up
location map set and also how to use the
the command and how to build up your
scripting procedure okay so and of
course you are going to have the the
comment line that we are going to use it
in the terminal with the welcome message
for grass and you are going to you is
possible we are going to use it and the
bash environment but you can use it also
under Python so you can import the grass
Python models and you can keep working
with with grass under Python now there
is a tendency to to work more under
Python but actually the syntax is a bit
more complex because you have to put a
lot of quotation and so on so I keep
working in the bash is faster for me but
feel free to to shift and change when
you get the the concept in mind so now
from from a practical how we are going
to use it and now all your going to
start it so my my always advice is
downloading a virtual machine from OS Oh
Jo live and probably all of you already
have it and and then following some
exercise that already they are build up
the OSS Jo live is a is a Linux virtual
machine that has been built up from you
from different developers you can go in
these internet site and just download it
and you have the advantage that all the
software for GIS are already solid over
there so there are there are all the GDL
there are
all day different just partial brows
just partial browser desktop navigation
map special tools web service and so on
so everything is already built over here
you have the instantly installation
procedure to use it as a virtual machine
but also to twist all the rest ajo
directly in your operating system so
this is something that I suggest if you
starting from scratch rather than going
to use Ubuntu and then install the
software that is a bit can be a bit
complex in the beginning this one is
already precooked and ready to go and
you can have also some sample data that
you can start to use it for get familiar
so in this context we're going to use
these two webpage for following up the
workshop so the first one is going to be
an exercise in entering in a grass
location am upset that already exists in
the virtual machine and this second one
is going to be to create a location
starting from completely from scratch so
when you are you have a database sorry a
file the TIFF that you are going to use
it to build up your your location I'm
upset okay ready no question for this I
think that the question will come out
during the exercise okay so let's let's
starting the virtual machine probably
you have already going on if you if you
have is going to be lock the password
for the virtual machine is user sometime
you have to type twice like now no like
now yes okay so over here you have you
have all the different software as we
mentioned that you can access from
careful
the control panel over here and in
particular we are going to use our
terminal so click on the terminal and we
are going to open we are going to open
the web page so for as you can see also
in my case I'm opening my the web page
then I'm going to follow inside the
Firefox of the virtual machine try not
to use the Firefox or another browser
from your Mac or PC because if not the
copy/paste is quite complex okay so then
if you click over here on the left you
can arrive to the special ecology
exercise ok and then if you go down to
grass we can click over here in the
grass 7 - ok
so there are going there are also other
exercises over here a bit more complex
so you can use it afterwards but this is
really the starting point how to start
and then you can go deep in some other
building up a procedure so we are going
to use this one as the first one
and then the second one is going to be
this one so you can click in this one
and we are going to follow step by step
this web page so you can you can
copy/paste because the comment they are
not going to be so many now might zoom
in a bit more yes and now it's going to
be quite straightforward so I will try
to work in this way that I have always
the command visible and the terminal
ready to to work and to enter and to
show to you ok so whenever you want to
start grass there are we can see
starting as a comment line or starting
as a graphical user interface ok so
let's start it first as a graphical user
interface
if you type grass 72 the week's Python
that is day is the graphical user
interface okay you have to specify yeah
Giza red look he's already complaining
this is the first complaining slash use
there is not a volatile grass location
that's why you have to really specify
very well where you are going to start
it okay so let's go to the second one to
the second line and they can say now
okay start grass here we can put our the
command of first before we exploit on
okay and we are going to say start grass
72 using this grass database enter in
this location and using this map set
have you see the stairs first second
third and we already mentioned where to
start
so as soon you enter you are going to
have the welcome message that we will
see now and the graphical user interface
they are going to pop up you are going
to have two graphical user interface is
two windows one for the display and one
for the command we will see now so over
here if you you are in this situation of
standby and the term adjust pressing
enter so this is the graphical situate
the typical situation welcome message of
grass so you have where how to access to
the manual the different version and out
to start in the graphical user interface
okay so in our contest our I mentioned
to you that when we are inside grass
grass was built up under a Bosch system
environmental framework
okay so over here you will have that the
advantage is that when you are here
you have all the Bosch command in all
the grass command ready for you so for
example oh I can list file in now in a
Bosch for you I will can list file
command Brian LS okay I list the file so
this is the Bosch command but I can run
on the grass okay so over here LS is
given to me the information about what
is under my my home and now I will go
deep in this concept okay so over here
we have the graphical user interface
that is build up in this way you have
for example over here you can you can go
quite when you go here you can see look
at raster map layer you just click over
here you select you select one map last
raster layer for example in permanent
look you can already see that under your
location you can see pair money piece
M&P start so you can see maps under
different map set okay okay and then you
do okay and it's going to appear on your
right side the map so this is the
display and this is always the account
this stuff so everybody has the two
windows open can you follow perfect over
here this raster one and you can
learning by yourself if you just keep
moving you can see all also all the
information over here and over here you
can start to see all the different
command that grasses and one of the
advantage of the graphical user
interface this is telling the
neighborhood neighborhood analysis
moving
is your tell you already the command
that is running okay so with a graphical
user interface you can start to learn it
the common line and even better for
example if we go let's open this one
anyone you can open any one as soon you
start clicking the and you start to put
a different option and flag check out
over here
you have the line of your common line
that is building then if you do copy you
copy this line you can put in the
scripting procedure so if you don't know
the syntax go in the graphical user
interface select what you want to do it
click the different option read the
manual like always read the manuals key
relp
that is very details read the manuals
see I want to do these I want to do that
one and you start to click and you will
have your command line already built up
ok for all the different command anyone
is going to be working perfect the same
so this is the aspect of how using the
graphical user interface to learn the
grass syntax ok perfect so concerning
the command is you if you want to have a
list of the command you can use these
tricks you can put for example our dot
because I want to use I want to see all
the command that are coming out on the
raster environment ok then if you press
tab twice it's going to list that you
say yes is going to list all the
different command that you want to use
it ok and then you pick up ok I want to
do quantile let me see if I can do
quantile in a raster mod in a raster map
ok our top quantile and I don't know if
I use it I don't know how to use it
help
and I can get the help of the quantile
of the command our contact this is a
really short help but of course after a
while you can identify identify very
fast which are the different one with
the different flag and if you need more
information you go online and you you
you see the full help ok and from here
you can start to build up your your
command yeah my quantile ok my input
parameter equal to and you put your map
and then how to put bins value and so on
so you build up your command as you as
you in G as you wish yeah and we will
see how to to use it yes
actually to have a long I think to have
a long yes with the man in front you can
have also the long help that to tell you
nothing else that is perfect is saying
the one that is on the web sometimes I
go to the web where sometimes I'm
already in the terminal so I just do man
and the command that I am see here and
they can see very fast at a different
command yeah ok so this is how you
access the capability of grass and how
you start learning the different option
of the command so there is this command
G G dot G's environment is nothing else
that like when you print the directory
so you want to see where are you under
grass ok so in this case again we are
under my G's database grass database my
location Europe and I'm upset permanent
so when you don't know where are you G
thought to Jesus environment a you get
the list ok so now everybody please pay
attention over here if I do print
working directory
PWD look where I am I am slash home
user so I am cure this is the tilde of
the home user I can change be careful I
can do CD OST for Sam so now I am asking
where I am in grass where I am okay
let's see I'm perfect in the same place
okay so be careful these up to here is
the location for grass I'm under Europe
map set firmly over here I am in the
folder where the Bosch command can be
release out to put where they are going
to be saved
out of it there are two directory one is
that there is the grass directory up to
here and this is the bosch directory so
what doesn't mean that everything that
has a now to put from grass raster or
vector from grass is going to be
splitted inside to these stairs
okay rather if you create something
underbrush is going to be in the s54 Sam
perfect so over here if I do LS is going
to print what is going to print my
command my folder that are under my OST
for Sam and I can see if you want a
graphical representation we can see over
here slash OST for Sam perfect the same
folder that I see over here
I see over here in the terminal so far
so clear no rather if I do something
weed grass command is going to be
splitted inside to these stairs okay so
just to give you a you have already see
an interface I mean a connection between
grass and Bosch I'm working with the to
command with the two software in the
same way under designer environment at
this point if you do are you can enter
from grass inside R and so what they are
going to bring all the location and map
set inside are already and you can
access the raster file so this is the
language communication that you cannot
achieve it in under different another
operating system or if you are is they
are not so flexible okay so this is
where you can of course over here you
can communicate and see and run an
import variable and and do whatever you
you want it okay so this is just to give
a feeling of the flexibility I'm not
expecting that you mastering already
this kind of connection so now is
important you have location for grass
and location for Bosch yes please
yeah in that case yes in that case is
your yes in in that case your working
directory of our is going to be OST for
Sam but you will be able to access to
the raster file in off grass okay so we
will this is a really language
integration that can come after a bit of
experience because you have to be good
in bashing grass and in are so and then
you can start to communicate between all
of them
okay print working directory so usually
what I do I do it
I always enter in the grass database so
usually I do like these I enter in grass
and then I me great inside to the grass
database so inside here you have your
location okay over here you can keep
doing stuff you can create files under
your Europe you can see that you still
you you are in they already in the grass
place you know in the grass location so
I will never mess up in this folder I
will not create additional file order
folder if you want to create something
that you are saving or like now to put
for some Bosch computation go in the
grass database go one level up don't
mess up with under that line okay so
here I can create a file a Co I don't
know this file test dot txt
unless so now I will have my location
and my text the docks teak steep for for
something okay
so just create a file you can create a
file under a grass Tibet database but
don't create one level down okay and
neither in the map set of course you can
have the you have the power of Bosch so
you can even completely remove Europe
your location in one shot but of course
then you cannot enter anymore in class
okay because you're breaking all this
structure so be careful also to if you
are in grass database be careful if you
have to remove something because you are
going to damage your full location and
map set clear so in my case I can remove
my test and now is gone
okay
so so now we we keep seeing all these
aspect of of the grass which now that we
saw that the aspect of grass database
the location map said there was this
this concept of the G region that we
need to understand so Jim upset - L is
given to me sorry the map set is given
to me the list of map set that are there
okay so now I was impermanent and be
careful about this one so the concept of
Maps at war was mainly for protecting
your data so when you are in one map set
you can create only in that map set you
can read from all the map set but you
can create only in the map set that you
are in so try to imagine why one is
called permanent what you save in this
permanent folder your input file that
arm to be you you don't want to mess up
with your input file you know so in the
permanent are the input file and they
ended p.m. in the older map set you can
have the out to put off the reading due
to that you can read from everywhere but
you can produce only where you are from
there you can have the output in this
way you don't make a mistake and delete
your input because you can only write
where are you
so if you are inside 2 p.m. you cannot
remove it what is gear you cannot
overwrite / you have to change them up
set and go in there and do so this is
the shifting that we are going to to
check so for example we were in
permanent ok G dot the Jesus environment
try to do it
we were impaired mind now I want to
change him upset
and I do GMaps set-piece M is tell you
with the war with a little warning okay
so now you are look now you are in peace
M so now we can see if I do again
gee-gees dot environment I can see now
that I am peace M over here
so I shift between map set okay so each
map set has his own G region so what
does mean that in the permanent you can
have a very huge teeth and then in the
map set you can have map set for this
region a map set for this other region
I'm upset for this other region
okay your input file is going to be one
but your map set and your output are
going to be for this region this region
and that region so these allow you
flexibility because you are not cropping
every time the file but you are using
the white file for producing something
small for example this concept in our
there is not so if you have a raster
file you have to crop it first
and then from that one you have to keep
going with a crop at one over here no
you just setting the there in the region
in a small area and then from there you
keep working in the in debt in that
aspect okay so now that we see how to
shift between map set I want to see what
there is inside this map set I want to
see the raster file so I do you do G
list rust and you can see actually if
you put minus P is a bit more well-well
build up so check I am in p.m. but I can
also read permanent read not write
everything that I write is going to be
in p.m. but I can also see my input
impairment I cannot see this em we the
other one so you can also allow to see
the file from that one this is going to
be readable and here is going to be in
readable and writing so now if you you
change again and you do the other one
was cold I was cold
yeah piece M start now I enter in piece
M stat and I redo the list look now I am
me I can see everything in piece M start
impairment I cannot see anymore the
other one okay so this is allow you to
to protect your data do not mess up and
of course you can have the same name of
raster in inside gear and it's IKEA but
because they are disconnected between
that I always suggest not to do it if
not you get confused if you want to exit
you just press Q perfect the same for
vector okay with the G list fact you can
see the vector that are inside here so
again they the to import command to and
when you enter G's dot invite Jesus
environment tell you where are you angie
list raster or vector tell you we what
is insider okay these are the raster and
again these are splitted inside all this
folder you don't see them you see as a
unique file but you can see in
particular if you want to go one level
deep understanding which kind of file I
have it was roster you can just take it
one keep it one anyone you can copy and
then you do our info
even if he is not the same man no
problem so what do you get now our info
is like it was like doodle info perfect
the same is give it to you the
information about the roster so in this
case you have a roster with the 441 and
740 lines with this extension minimum
maximum okay so we mentioned before that
you have the capability of Bosch combine
it with the one with the R so what we're
sorry we do one with grass so what that
doesn't mean so means that for example
you are printing this information with
with grass but you are interesting not
in everything but all in this line so
this one every time that you print
something is a terminal output okay so
that is a text that you can manipulate
with Bosch command so in this case for
example I want to just get information
so grab this line that contain minimum
maximum so range so if you have if you
are if you want to have just this line
you can just adding a Bosch option and
you can get just that one if you want
only the last number because you are
interesting in the in the max you can
using another command oak command that
you can say print one two three four
five six seven eight nine ten dollar ten
is going to be my last column my command
number 20 okay and of course these one
then can become a variable that you can
import in R for example can be a text
file that you want import in our so over
here you you start to see the Ephesians
of you are doing something grass but you
are retrieving by combining bash command
retrieving a number then then you can
bring inside to another in over here you
can see the flow you can build up the
typical flow that everybody is talking
about but I don't know how many people
are building up to this flow chart and
they say ok so this is the connection
that you can build and do it ok
appealing so if you want to adding
information if you want to if you see
that in G list for example you want to
see also the order G dot list roster so
in this case you were you will see all
the information for one for one map set
but if you if you do it this one Jim
upset and you put the other one so be
careful if you are in one you have to
put the other one p.m. because I was
changing a few times now if I list again
now I can see everything
do you see now I can see before I I
could see these two now I can see
everything and of course I can also read
this file so this is like you open the
door you leave it open okay but you
still in the same one you are still in
there
again if you don't know geeze
environment ok
okay so I would say spend maybe three
four minutes to do this kind of
operation me great check where are you
and you say okay I want to enter in
these mapset and then get a file and get
to the information of this file with our
info okay
so again using viral g1 oh and again you
you just check the command that we did
you get this one and say okay let me
enter here you entering one you listed
you pick up a file and you see the
information of this file
can you change me great
can you change from one to what the
other one okay
okay
any
any question can you do it or not tell
me tell me can you get an info or not
are in front gate could you change your
location map said I'll get maps eternal
ok map said ok cool
so now let's see when I mentioned to you
that we can read file from another
location do something let's see this is
the concept you had to change a bit this
line because V model is am upset that is
not anymore there so let's build and gap
together you just least one so you can
you you are in your I am in piece M
start for example so I want to read
something that is Anja in another
directory in another map set so I can I
can list G list
roster okay with always with - P so just
pick up another one for example this one
piece M realize in my case you can copy
this file and then you can see ok let me
copy in my in my directory in my
permanent so you can see G copy raster
from piece M and you say at
PSM from and then you give the two it's
going to be my piece em realized to you
is the cop is always from to I want to
gobble this file that is located in my
in these older map set and bring it here
with another name now if you copy is
going to say copy raster map set that
was in PCM and copy where in peace m2
that is the your current map set so now
if you list it now you have the two over
here okay the file is super protected
because you cannot remove it that one
but you can copy there and do something
else and now at this point for example
you can remove that file you can remove
that file so G remove minus F type rust
and you remove the one that you copied
so now you are removing the file and is
fine you can remove it this is to show
you that even if files are in another
map set you can still access by giving
at the location where they are at p.m.
and of course you can also copy stuff
that are in the permanent but for the
same but usually in the permanent area
you have your input data so you just
maybe you want to just copy the input
data try to do something and then see if
it's working or not okay please
well it is also because even if you try
to remove let me try if you try to
remove the one in PCM okay you can't
because you have to enter in that map
set and then you can remove it so every
action that produce a now to put an
action it is a strong action you can you
can ask the list there are info of a
file that is another one but you cannot
remove it our info r dot info of this
file you can do it because you are not
just getting an info but you cannot
create something you cannot do a now to
put and of course they remove it is not
possible so this allows you to to have
your file extremely protect you can keep
working that permanent file that
permanent as you as you go on with
analysis okay so the G removal we
mentioned okay so now we are in this G
region so we mentioned about the G
region the G region a few times in the
presentation a also in the in the
example but now let's see impractical
what they are this G region okay so if
you do G region minus P you can see that
your your corner of this region okay so
by the graphical user interface if you
still open if you still open you can see
also changing this G region so over here
if you do and this is helping you so if
you do try to do it with any map that
you have is fine
if you do over here setting region and
you do display region so setting region
display region over here is going to
print the region that you are you are
okay so over here you say okay I have
this map I want to focus just in this
area I want to set in my G region over
there so you you can go to raster now
actually it was not in raster it was
over here so you can do over here you
can zoom and you can say set
computational region extend from display
or extent interactive so now you zoom in
one area as soon you release your region
is set and if you print back again this
one
now you can see that that the region has
been changed so before you were look 400
point 4 under rose now you have 320 so
these are you can okay let me setting a
bit the region and checking what is
going on okay and from now on all my
analysis will be use it on that way this
is the with a graphical user interface
now you can see how you can do it with a
common line okay but of course for
example this one can be useful to see
your your corner you know okay let me
see in Norway how they are this corner
and then you can get this corner and put
in a common line for your regional
setting and this is perfect the same
when you do over here G region look the
G region now has been changed it's 320
rather before it was 441 okay
so again now if you do some how to put
and we will see is going to be only for
that area
you can go back to the previous region
if you do Gd Jonas - D so when you
create a location we will see the G
region is your full extent if you do an
action then you can bid use it and then
if you do the minus D is bringing back
to the full extent so in this case okay
let me test everything with a small
solid region when you are ready you put
the G region - D and you extend so you
can change the G region also giving the
parameter of north-south and s in east
and so on and you can overwrite and in
the meantime you can also save it as a
file for a later use okay so you can if
you can imagine you can build up and now
we are going to see this file so you run
in this one Scandinavia so let's see to
see where these file is so if you say LS
LS Europe we were I was in G dot G's
environment so I was in PCM so peace and
peace I'm start
default wind
and to the reckless find
inside here under permanent windows I
have my file ok so inside here you will
have
inside windows you will have all your
map set this Conda Naevia is what is
what is just a text file my Scandinavia
in just a text file now question can I
create these text file with some other
software and rather the crane
Scandinavia I can create tiles yes so
you can create the tiles 1 x 2 x 3
transfer and then what you can do it
each single side the full location you
send to the node and each single size is
going to be processed by one CPU okay so
in that case you are in the multi-core
process but require a bit of time but
there there where you can arrive ok
knowing these tricks nothing else and
everything is defined by raster image
vector image and in text file that can
be manipulated under order software
command line you can even open this one
with a with a with a we need eater like
G edit
and then you go here and you change you
say okay rather than these I want this
you save it close save it close and now
if you print again your map set I told
ye yeah G region minus P now you have
the number modified by another software
okay so that's these are just text file
that you can use it so we saw the G
region setting that can be done by
graphical user interface in in that way
by zooming I didn't use so much this one
just use it for for didactic extend it
out extent from display so if you do in
display is going to take the full the
full region if you do min this area and
then you do setting from this play now
Yorgi region is going to be so big so if
you go back over here and you reprint
you can see that the row now has been
changed okay
row 2000 you are one thousand and more
so you can play as you want with the G
richer
okay so let's see an example
so I set up the region in that way and I
want to do a calculation so I want to
take a file Jill is the roster sorry G
list minus P okay
so I want to take let's take these F
nfpc
you can take again you can take any one
so now you do for example our our map
calc let's allow you to make a
calculation and you say okay create my
crop equal to FN FC my original one
times I don't know to ^ to whatever so
now as you can see that the computation
has been quite is quite fast my my
region is very small
now if I plot my new map that is going
to be in my where I was in PCM start
crop apply ok so now my map is molar ok
so I process only for that area and of
course from there you can adding more
command it's going to be able to put
only for these and then before to expand
it you do minus D let's try G region
minus D I think that minus D is already
the full extent and now if you reprocess
now you have to overwrite yeah look now
it's computing is already symbol is
already going small not so fast
look how it I was more how slowly is
going because it's bigger okay so and of
course when you want to testicle you
cannot wait all this time perfect
so you can bring it back to Scandinavia
I think you need to put that the command
day
gee region
Keynesian - Pete
named raster you can set set up the G
region base also to other vector file my
case is a text file so region equal so I
can do region equal
it was Danny
so now I bring him back today to the
original out of boot and now that I want
to run so now he's going faster because
it smaller okay so this is how you you
play with these tools okay I think we
recover quite yeah these resolute is
cropping it is what I just mentioned now
with the different something that you
also can change is the resolution of
your pixel so you can setting you can
certain regions continue you can setting
there when we did a full line with the
north and south you can also add ink so
when you add in this one you can also
not adding the resolution is one or
resolution equal to 20,000 okay so what
does mean you setting up the resolution
for day out to put not for your input so
now rest it's not rest
press equal value
because
so now you can set in the resolution now
if you rerun the computation is even
fastest already over and if you refresh
you have the resolution change it ok so
again you can keep smaller but also
change the resolution your underline
these are just the out to put the your
underline map is still the same didn't
change is whatever they are to put is
the outer it's just a faster or a
sampling technique to allow you to see
what is going on okay so you can change
the resolution yeah these are example I
just made it okay and the visualization
we we already did it okay you won't have
bit of time like before two three four
five minutes to to play a bit change the
resolution and try run our map calc and
you can see over here that the command
you can try setting different region
make an output and then see the
difference and so on
for just afford a display I think for
qgis is missing a plug-in that allows
you to import the data or at least is
not in this version I have to check
better yes I think they I have to read
in some forum I was reading before and I
seems that it is not yet available for
these coogee is version so it's
available for the previous one but in
the end I adjust I use it the graphical
user interface of grass just for fast
visualization then when you get familiar
in your processing is you can how to put
a TIF and then the TIF you can open with
any software you know so I just do it in
this way and every time that I close I
just put out to put it as a TIF and then
I open with open TV or some others yeah
okay
okay
so just wrap up this section so we saw G
dot G is environment and to see that
where are you under environment of under
grass we see G dot list for listing
roster we sold so how to change the
different map set with the G map set add
or switching and then from there you can
adding the different these are the most
but the black the black box of grass and
then from here you can keep adding the
different script in line and proceed you
one behind the order are quite
straightforward and then of course you
can search for out how to make a buffer
out to make our neighborhood and so on
but these are the key party to is very
important to understand so these walls
again for doing something that already
exist so now we are going to the option
okay now you go home I have my teeth my
shape file I want to start a grass
location and when you start and then you
are going to follow all this procedure
to do it but let's see one step before
how we can do it so so exit completely
so you can write exit so please be sure
that you exit so you are back your you
are back in your brush directory just so
at this point now should start
okay so at this point you just enter
grass 72 who exploit on okay so this is
the graphical user interface that you
can use to enter by a location select
your location you navigate if you is not
appearing navigate over here and you you
can select so for doing this let's
create a first a directory so you can
you come you can see or you close this
one and we create first a detector I
think is easier so if you just create a
directory so you do make dear OST for
Sam grass DB new so this is something
completely new that you are going to
create and you can put the option - are
in this way is going to over writing
invalid option sorry I think you don't
have these these directory make the
grass database new yeah just create a
completely empty directory so now now
that you create a directory completely
empty you open your grass you migrate in
the completely empty directory so user
OST for Sam grass database new
okay so now you have the complain of
grass there is no location there is no
map set so now you are going to do new
new location okay you've write up your
name the name of the location you can
put for example Europe - now the best
option you just click Next
is to use a file that already have the
reference system so now if you do
project this one so read the projection
in that'm from a file system so now if
you do like this is going to ask okay
which file you want to do it so you go
into your directory and you pick up the
one that you want to use it to build up
your so in this case you can grass
database sorry in the exercise there are
some files you can pick up any file
geology are and you can pick up this one
for example input project if so you'd go
OST for some exercise basic input
project octave and over there you are
ready to click and to have everything
ready to go he is asking if you want
imported you say yes ok successfully
imported and now you are under grass
database new Europe to is creating an
automatically the permanent in-situ
Department is going to be this file that
has been great and this you can see so
now is starting all the grass but you
did nothing else
that over here you create this one a
Europe to permanent and inside all these
structure that I say before so this is
how you do it with a graphical user
interface you can do it with our teeth
or you can do it also with a shape file
is the same okay so first thing to do it
empty folder actually I also insert in
the empty folder then the teeth that I
want to use it this way I remember that
that location has been created with that
fill with that file with that projection
and everything okay and you build up
everything
okay I think this is quite
straightforward you are following
without probably any question about this
procedure now that you I think now that
you have in mind the three step is
coming easier know isn't it
okay so let's see let's see the other
exercise with with a graphical user
interface sorry with a command line so
if you if you go again back to the grass
over here and you scrolling down you you
do this one create location using
ancillary layer with a common line the
first one
okay now you will see that is even
easier with a common line okay so and
probably we can comment even together
and then we can run so the first one
Bosch people come on you know first one
remove the folder perfect then making a
new one completely empty then copy this
file to to the directory okay just copy
then people in the first workshop
okay they find the projection be sure
that this file is with the 43:26 because
we mentioned that and we mention air
repeat try always to build up location
with a file that has the right
projection you are 100% sure that is the
right projection and also all the
parameter already filled up in this way
you can be sure if you are signed on an
ApS g-code that in this case the 43:26
is the fuji SAT for that Google and
mobiles and everybody's using okay so
now that you are here you can use this
file - you are sure okay just remove the
new location and then you do the use
class 72 in text mode using this file
name of the location name of the
location and then location path of the
grass database that's it very easy and
is building up everything okay so we can
try step by step you can also go for it
you can cop even more line okay now I
copy
I make a digital warp to be sure that my
projection is correct how we can see I
can see David I have projection now we
can see very projection G da ji doll
come on Brian I'm waiting for you did
Ally info okay now you can have a
projection you have a PS gf 24 you can
see that is good file and now you can
run this line
to build up the grass okay he's entering
in automatically in grass but his empty
there is nothing G dot list rust
completely empty so he's building up
only the folder and actually if you see
there is not is also not completely
build up so we are in OST for Sam
clutter database new look you have the
new location the permanent inside
apartment you you don't have yet
all the folder so now at this point you
import the data so in these you can do
it with the are until input are in GDL
that you can import this is the command
to import in its I grass so now through
ingest it G list you have your file
input approach and now all the different
cells lah cell has been created okay
it's no it's not difficult if you find
these four lines you build up your
location without struggling okay
but again pay attention that the file
has to be with the right projection okay
what do you mean transform so if you
want to over here you want to this is
target source here you put another
number now I don't know how to look it
but you put another number is going to
be for 40 to 20 change it and then you
report it yeah this is define the
projection you are just giving the right
number you are not changing the
projection system yeah but of course yes
there are
you're changing yeah so any question
this direction I have one question for
you you will be able to build up
location with your data now if you go
home okay if you do in one month no but
if you do tomorrow I think it would this
is the aim know if you if you are able
to build up location map set state
forward and then and then you proceed
slowly and build up with your scripting
procedure but this is the way okay so
try to use as much as possible these
tools in the beginning the learning
phase is quite slowly but then all the
time you are going to receive back
because you'll be more efficient faster
and then everything okay yeah
you can build up a scripting procedure
to import all the file with a for loop
for file in all the teeth user in GDL
done is going to import all the teeth
that you have in the directory okay be
careful they this one just to let you
know there is RNG that is importing the
data so you you will have a data
duplication you will have your teeth and
then inside to the location map set you
will have yeah the same file so double
so if you go in the massive data process
having two terabyte to replicate is not
really convenient so there is a command
that is r dot external that is just
create a link is not important that if
we just create a link so it's something
that you can use afterwards keep in mind
not for now but keep in mind yeah so
this is what's for there for the grass
workshop so if you have question in this
contest or free yeah
free free charting how we can use it do
you figure we can be done these and how
yeah we can I've spend a few minutes to
for your question
to a location harder
sorry can we import
yeah so this for loop this will for file
in all the teeth important with using RG
doll done it's going to report all of
them yeah so all the for loop you can
use it by importing you can use it under
gear importing greater buffer and
exporting for example or can be this for
loop can be even longer okay
I think away like to display about
so grass is very tight with the
projection so I always mentioned I
always suggest to working in one
specific projection in grass do all the
computation and then if you need you
export it you change which it'll warp
and then you visualize okay so because
the the projection in grass you can
create also different location with
different projection I working more a
global level so I always work with wgs84
so I don't dealing so much with the
projection but if I have it I prepare my
data before to enter in grass and when I
am in grass I'm sure that everything is
under the same projection system because
he's very picky he's going to complain a
lot yeah okay
okay so this was for four to four today
so next workshop is going to be on the
application or hydrological modeling
using grass okay there are plenty of
modules in grass I mean we just saw how
to start it and now but there are really
really many many many and you can do all
the different kind of all the different
kind of computation you can do it you
want to get the Instagram of an image
you want to do supervisor circulation
what will our mixing analysis in email
in many many many watershed analysis for
hydrological modeling correlation
between two raster big huge correlation
between tolya raster you can do it they
are started to do it also there are
models for do machine learning machine
learning for image analysis and over
there is is going more and more and more
so this is the the capability that you
can have under your fingers and next
next workshop is going to be for
ideological modeling even if you are not
dealing with a hydrological model I
would suggest to come because you get a
feeling of what you can do it in general
and then you can apply to your
vegetation map or to your animal pattern
or okay so this is the and then in
particular I'm going to point to this in
may we are going to have this one-week
training over here and we are going to
cover this of course I'm going to start
the grass again from scratch but they're
going to be models from learning for our
Python in the geographical domain
language integration so that one is
going to be quite appealing to to follow
up because you can leveraging even more
don't think that is going to be one week
because this week is coming back to you
because if you are going to do it the
same starting location and everything we
will take 2-3 days for you to do it now
you go home
10 minutes done okay so it's really you
gain time if you follow a procedure and
you have material where you can do it
again okay
so spread the news also for this one I'm
going to stick all these leaflet around
campus but you want more arc here and
you can paste in your department and so
on and that's it you have keep keep
working under I will Manning office
hours every Wednesday and Friday over
here so feel free to come when is in the
library and Friday over here feel free
to come and discuss in project and yeah
welcome
[Music]